avec francis choisel historien
spécialiste de la constitution de la
vème république bonsoir pas ce qu'ils
faisaient
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur
arte france alors voilà qui rappelle de
constitution le texte a de larges
chances d'être adopté un dans un
hémicycle quand même majorité
présidentielle alors que le sénat l'a
rejeté pas plus tard que ce matin
oui et dès lors que l'assemblée adopte
le texte le sénat au plus rien faire
dans les républiques précédentes
il fallait un accord entre l'assemblée
qui s'appelait chambre des députés sous
la troisième république et le sénat pour
qu'un texte passe sous notre
constitution
après une navette entre le sénat et
l'assemblée la sort dé l'assemblée peut
avoir le dernier mot
dès lors que le voulait le gouvernement
a décidé c'est ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui
alors on entend effectivement ces
députés qui sont peu content ce qui est
en jeu pour eux c'est un texte jugé
lippert liberticide
c'est l'avis du constitutionnaliste que
vous êtes également
il est évident que dans la mesure où
people il reprend le où semble-t-il
l'épidémie est terminée
aucune pression de restreindre les
libertés ou plus exactement il n'y a
aucune règle en debré voire à l'avant ce
que le gouvernement dans un claquement
de doigt quelque sorte leur espace et
libertés on pourrait très bien imaginer
si l'épidémie repartait que le parlement
soit convoqué pour autoriser le
gouvernement à prendre des mesures
exceptionnelles
mais là dans la situation dans laquelle
nous nous trouvons on doit au poil
jusqu'au 30 octobre
le gouvernement a carte blanche pour
mettre entre parenthèses la liberté de
circulation la liberté de réunion et la
liberté de manifestation s'attendre
france et choisel à ce que le conseil
d'état jouent un rôle on a vu qu'il
avait été saisi plusieurs fois et que
parfois les requérants avaient eu gain
de cause est ce que sur ce plan il ya
cette dernière juridiction qui peut
faire recours
non parce que le conseil d'état
intervient avant le vote de la loi celui
qui va intervenir
notre ou comme on peut le voir ce sera
le conseil constitutionnel car
l'opposition peut saisir le conseil
constitutionnel sur la
constitutionnalité des lois
même le président du sénat tout seul a
la possibilité de céder de saisir le
conseil constitutionnel puisque le sénat
dans sa majorité a voté contre cette loi
il est fort possible que gérard larcher
décide tout seul ni au nom du sénat de
saisir le conseil constitutionnel
il est possible aussi que le président
de la république et saisisse le conseil
constitutionnel pourquoi non pas parce
qu'il est opposé à la loi mais parce que
si c'est lui qui s'exilent pour ces
constitutionnel et que le conseil
constitutionnel sanctionne la loi ce ne
sera pas une victoire pour l'opposition
ce sera mis au crédit du président de la
république qui a pris toutes ses
précautions démocratique pour le faire
et puis enfin si le n'y a ni l'autre ne
saisisse le conseil constitutionnel
soixante sénateurs ou 60 députés peuvent
saisir le conseil constitutionnel c'est
prévu par la constitution
pour qu'une minorité puisse saisir le
conseil constitutionnel donc même à
l'assemblée où l'opposition est
minoritaire
soixante députés c'est peu par rapport
au non au chiffre du nombre de députés
d'opposition 60 députés posent saisir le
conseil constitutionnel
alors le président de la commission des
lois de la chambre haute un énième en
hausse il le disait dit avoir
l'impression que le gouvernement veut
conserver les moyens de l'état d'urgence
sans le dire et il plein nos concitoyens
en plus besoin de vérité de
responsabilité que de risquer une forme
d'infantilisation est on est on en est
là conserver les moyens d'état d'urgence
sans le dire ça veut dire qu'à une forme
de tromperie en tout cas de la part
de l'opinion veut fait débat c'est un
peu ce que rapporter votre journaliste
bonjour progrès paul terme
d'infantilisation certes dans toute
cette crise et même en dehors de cette
crise on a tendance tous gouvernements
confondus depuis quelques années afin
d'utiliser les français mais je trouve
que c'est assez faible là on est dans
une atteinte aux libertés
ces mesures ne répète que ce que je
disais à l'instant c'est une carte
blanche au gouvernement s'était
d'instruction des pouvoirs
extraordinaires pour que le gouvernant
par simple décret c'est d'ailleurs sans
consultation du parlement ou même un
préfet dans un dans un département
puissent prendre des mesures qui
empêchent n'importe quel citoyen de se
déplacer correctement de se réunir
ajoutez à cela que le gouvernement a
annoncé qu'il reprenait un certain
nombre de réformes
il a annoncé qu'il voulait reprendre les
réformes
la réforme des retraites donc le
gouvernement pourra interdire des
réunions qui sont faites dans des salles
contre la réforme des retraites pour
interdire des manifestations alors on
entendait un député d'ille il ya
d'autres outils disponibles alors la vie
justement du spécialiste de la
constitution y à t'il dont trompiez
disponible pour pour pour aboutir
l'équivalent de l'état ça ni de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire
je prouverai le droit de manifestation
qui est comment fonctionne ne le droit
de manifestation dans le système actuel
avec l'actuel et d'irlande dont le dal
dans la règle normale on déclare on va
faire une manifestation et on l'a fait
mais mais le gouvernement a la
possibilité de l'interdire mais là on a
inversé les choses il faut demander
l'autorisation
donc voyez même dans le système normal
le gouvernement peut interdire une
manifestation moi j'ai eu l'occasion
personnellement dans un cadre politique
d'organiser des manifestations
et bien il y a eu un contact avant la
manifestation pour voir comment ça
allait se passer
et puis la manifestation a été autorisée
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que même
dans le cadre actuel le gouvernement
dispose de la possibilité d'interdire à
titre exceptionnel une manifestation
merci francis loisel d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur arte france rappelle
que vous êtes spécialiste de la
constitution de la vème république merci
à vous